[Música]
a
en eeuu la nueva ola del coronavirus
está echando a todo el país con unos
100.000 casos nuevos cada día el
gobierno insiste en que los casos más
graves que requieren que los pacientes
estén en cuidados intensivos son de
personas que no están vacunadas la
aparición de la variante delta ha
empeorado las cosas especialmente en
aquellos que no han sido inoculados y es
que según datos oficiales sólo el 60% de
la población de todo el país ha recibido
por lo menos una a dos y estos expertos
advierten de la desconfianza que hay por
la vacuna en algunos segmentos de la
población especialmente en los más
jóvenes donde se ha visto un incremento
de contagios en las últimas semanas un
estudio pronostica que desde ahora y
hasta el mes de diciembre morirán más de
100.000 personas en toda la nación
florida es actualmente el epicentro de
la pandemia lo que más preocupa a las
autoridades locales es el estrés
hospitalario porque sólo entre el 3 y el
6 por ciento de las camas de las ucis
estarían disponibles actualmente a pesar
de todo su gobernador se niega a
implementar alguna medida anti kobe
[Música]
i
la variante del tav ha provocado un
aumento sustancial de los casos de kobe
19 lo que ha llevado a guatemala al
momento más crítico desde que inició la
pandemia esta tercera ola ha causado el
desborde de los centros hospitalarios y
extenuación del personal médico que ha
explicado que la atención se complica
más en este país porque deben atender a
las víctimas de otra pandemia la
violencia y los accidentes de tránsito
con más de 16 millones de habitantes
guatemala registra más de 11.000 muertes
por coronavirus y las autoridades de
salud han advertido que si el actual
ritmo de contagio persiste la situación
podría tornarse caótica y que en octubre
se podrían registrar 25.000
fallecimientos sin embargo medios
locales reportaron que los departamentos
que han detectado la variante todavía no
toman medidas
los expertos han recomendado que se
aumente el ritmo de la vacunación pero
el índice de esquema completo es de los
más bajos del continente según
organismos internacionales
menos de un millón de personas tienen
las dos dosis de la vacuna es decir el 6
por ciento de los habitantes
[Música]
tras la desastrosa gestión de reír
bolsonaro de lo que es la pandemia en
brasil un presidente negador que retrasó
la compra de las vacunas y que hoy es
investigado por una comisión
parlamentaria en en el congreso nacional
los brasileños tienen ahora una corrida
contra el tiempo contra la variante
delta que ya está en 18 provincias del
lugar lo estáis 18 provincias del país
sus 60 por ciento de las oraciones no ya
acceder a la primera dosis de vacuna
pero solamente a 20 8% volvió para la
segunda 2 es ahora el gobierno quiere
dar un refuerzo a las personas mayores
de 70 años e inmunodeprimidas que eso en
la simula deprimidas personas que viven
con sida cáncer o ya fueron
trasplantadas es una corrida cuando el
tiempo como como ya hablamos y es algo
que los especialistas dicen que es
urgente